ON BEHALF OF-THE ENTIRE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE TEAM WE WANT
TO WELCOME YOU TO OUR FEBRUARY
SECOND EDITION OF THE COMMITTEE.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE COMING TO
ORDER AT PLEASE MAKE NOTE THAT
WE DO HAVE FOUR MEMBERS HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE BEFORE
WE GET INTO SOME INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS FOR INTERNET OVERTURNED
CHIEF CONSULTANT CONGER NOW TO
BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A KERR
MISTER NOW. SENATOR MCGUIRE HERE
WIRE PRESIDENT SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN PRESIDENT SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO PRESENT SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER PRESENT IN WINNER IS
MAKING OUT- SENATOR HERTZBERG'S-
TARDINESS MY RIGHT ANSWER WIENER
. HE WILL BEGIN THE WAR THE
RICARDO LARA AWARD- AS WELL SO-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT AT TO A RAMS FAN
HERE TODAY AT LEAST THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A PUSH BACK- FROM
FORTY NINE COUNTRIES ALL RIGHT
SO IN RESPONSE TO THE CALL THE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC. LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WHO MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES WE'RE
GONNA BE HOLDING HEARINGS HERE
IN THE CAPITAL INTO DATE NOW
THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED CORN OUT
WE ARE GOING TO BE MOVING
FORWARD ON ONE BUILDING IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. NOW WE
WELCOME PUBLIC PARTICIPATION WE
WELCOME EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
TO BE ABLE TO CALL OUR TOLL FREE
TELECONFERENCE WINE THAT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR THAT CODE IS
THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT
THREE AND REPEAT OUR TOLL FREE
NUMBER EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR WITH A
CODE OF THREE FIVE THREE TWELVE
EIGHTY THREE YEAH WHEN WE DO
MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU CAN
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. IN THE UNLIKELY
EVENT THAT SOMEONE BECOMES
DISRUPTIVE HEARING ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE OR ON OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCE FIND THAT
INDIVIDUAL WILL BE REMOVED BUT
AGAIN THAT IS AN UNLIKELY EVENT
WE ONLY HAVE ONE BILLING TODAY'S
AGENDA THERE ARE NO BILLS
PROPOSE FOR CONSENT. I AM WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM WE'RE
GOING TO WELCOME OUR FIRST AND
ONLY AUTHORED CENTER LAYERED
HERE- AND PRIOR TO CENTER
LAYERED GETTING STARTED I JUST
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE GOOD SENATOR. HE
HAS BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY. ON
SENATE BILL FOR EIGHTEEN. IN
THIS IS A LITTLE OF A DIFFERENT
PROCESS WE TYPICALLY SEE THIS
WILL BE A CONCURRENCE VOTE
TODAY. AS WE KNOW THE ORIGINAL
SB FOURTEEN WAS PASSED LAST YEAR
THE SENATE AMENDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND APPROVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY. AND I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO BE ABLE TO KNOWLEDGE
SENATOR LAYER. HE REACHED OUT
EARLY TO THIS COMMITTEE HIS
STAFF WORK WITH THIS COMMUNITY
DILIGENTLY. ON POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS. THOSE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE COMMITTEE WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO USHER INTO THIS BILL. AT
WE WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
INTERLAYER TOUGHEST. AND THE
CHAIRWOMAN OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CECILIA AGUIAR-CURRY TO ENSURE
THAT ALL AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
CARE OF IN THE IN IN IN THE
ASSEMBLY. SO AGAIN THIS IS JUST
GONNA BE CONCURRING IN THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDS. AND WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU AGAIN IT'S AN
EARLIER FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND WE
DO HAVE YOUR- LEAD WITNESS ON
THE LINE. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- YOU BY HELP
TO ME BY SHORTENING MY-
PRESENTATION WITH WHAT YOU SAID
AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
ASSISTANCE. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT MIGHT NOT KNOW ABOUT THIS.
WATSONVILLE IS A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY-
IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AT LARGE
WHICH INCLUDES SOME WEALTHIER
AREAS THERE'S EIGHTY PERCENT.
ARE FREE AND REDUCED SCHOOL
LAUNCHERS IN THE DISTRICT
THERE'S 35% ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. 82% LATINO INSIDE THE
CITY LIMITS OF WATSONVILLE. AND
THIS HOSPITAL WHAT'S IN THE
HOSPITAL. IS ONE OF TWO FULL
SERVICE. HOSPITALS IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. OUR IT PROVIDES SERVICES
FOR REACH AND SIX HUNDRED TWO
FIVE AND- TWO HUNDRED PHYSICIANS
THIS IS NOT A SMALL OPERATION.
IN NOVEMBER THE HEDGE FUND THAT
OWNS THE HOSPITAL. ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY WERE GONNA CLOSE TO
TWO WEEKS AND WHILE FALL BEFORE
THEY SEND OUT NOTICES TO THE
EMPLOYEES. IN THE INTERVENING
TIME BANKRUPTCY COURT INTERVENED
WHEN THEY FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY.
AND WE ARE VERY LUCKY THAT
THERE'S A COMMUNITY GROUP THAT
IS ORGANIZED WITH SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY SALUTE BOTTLE HAND DAVID
CLINIC THE POWER OF OUR HELP
TRUST WITH THE SUPPORT OF
MONTEREY COUNTY. AND THE AND THE
CITY OF WATSONVILLE AND THERE
FORMED A GROUP THAT HAS PASSED
FOR A PUBLIC HOSPITAL DISTRICT
TO BE ABLE TO PURCHASE THE
HOSPITAL. THE BANKRUPTCY COURT
THROUGH NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
CURRENT OWNER GAVE THIS GROUP
THE FIRST RIGHT OF PURCHASE. BUT
THE OFFER THE BILL HAS TO BE
MADE IN THREE WEEKS. AND IT
WOULD HAVE TWO MONTHS TO CLOSE
SO WERE OPERATING IN STAGES THIS
BILL AS THE CHAIR SAID HAS BEEN
A RECORD IT WAS AMENDED. FOR THE
FIRST TIME TWO WEEKS AGO FRIDAY
IN THE ASSEMBLY. WAS REFERRED
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY IN THE
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY OFF THE
FLOOR THIS IS HERE AND IF YOU
PASS IT TODAY I HOPE TO SEND IT
TO THE GOVERNOR TOMORROW. AND
THEN THIS WILL ALLOW DISTRICT
FOR THE PLEDGES THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE TO BY THE HOSPITAL TO BE IN
EFFECT BY THE TIME OF THE- OF
THE BIDS. AND AS THE CHAIR SAID
. R. GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE TOOK
A BILL ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
AND A MAN TO DO IT- THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THIS
COMMITTEE WE CONSULTED WITH
BECAUSE WE SAID WE WANT TO TAKE
WHATEVER AMENDMENTS ARE NEEDED
IN THE ASSEMBLY TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THIS BILL. INTERNET
EXPEDITIOUS FASHION. AND WE TOOK
TO CHIEF AMENDMENTS WHAT WHICH
WAS THAT. IF THE PROJECTS UNABLE
TO PURCHASE THE HOSPITAL
DISTRICT OF THIS ALL OF THE
PROJECT EVER CELLS THE HOSPITAL
THE DISTRICT WILL BE SOLVED.
THERE WAS SOME CONCERN ABOUT
REPORTS AND I PLEDGE. TO DO A
CLEAN BILL OF PEOPLE NEEDED TO-
SEVEN HADN'T REQUIRED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE STOPS
AND SLOW THIS PROCESS DOWN SO
THAT WE CAN GET THIS TO THE
GOVERNOR IN FACT TO BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE THE HOSPITAL. AND IT IS
AN EMERGENCY MEASURE. SO THAT IT
GOES INTO A FACT THE MINUTE THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED SO THIS IS A
RECORD SPEED FOR NON BUDGET
BILLS BUT THIS IS AN URGENT
CRISIS WE NEED TO SAVE THE
HOSPITAL FOR THE PEOPLE INVOLVED
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE. ALL THE
HELP BECAUSE HELP IN THE
AMENDMENTS TO MOVE IT WAS HELP
IN SETTING A HEARING QUICKLY SO
THAT I CAN TAKE IT UP ON THE
FLOOR TOMORROW APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S HELP IN MAKING THIS
HAPPEN I HAVE ANYBODY THAT
PARKWAY OR HAS REPRESENTED.
WATSON GO ON THE BILLS SO
ROBERT RIVAS AND MARK STONE OF
CROFTERS AND SENATOR CAFIERO IS
A CO AUTHOR WHO ONCE REPRESENTED
ONCE WITH THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS I WOULD ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I HAVE A
WITNESS ON THE PHONE JEAN HURST
ON BEHALF OF THE PAPAROA VALLEY.
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT PROJECT
BOARD I DON'T THINK SHE'S GOING
TO TAKE VERY LONG AND SHE LIKE
ME WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THE MOVE THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR MOTION FOR MY CENTER DRIVE
SO WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT UP TO
MISS HEARST ISSUES REGARDING THE
POTTER VALLEY HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT- AND WE ALSO WANT TO.
LET MISTER SNOW THAT WE DO WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO WE'RE
GONNA ASK MISS HEARST FOR
TRUNCATED VERSION OF HER REMARKS
THIS HURST WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE OF UP TO TWO MINUTES
AND I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT. HIRST CALLING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSORS OF SB
FOUR EIGHTEEN THE PROPER VALLEY
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT PROJECT
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AT SENATOR
LEHRER HAS THOUGHTFULLY LAID OUT
AT THE NEED FOR THE BILL AND WE
ALSO WANT TO EXTEND OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR YOU MISTER
CHAIR INTEREST YOUR STAFF. I'M
AS WE WORK THROUGH THOSE
AMENDMENT IN THE ASSEMBLY WE
APPRECIATE GREATLY- EVERYONE'S
COMMITMENT TO GETTING US TO THIS
PLACE SO THAT WE CAN HELP KEEP
THE WATSONVILLE COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL OPEN WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK ON THAT IS WELL WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE WITH US
TODAY AND I KNOW YOU'LL BE
STANDING BY FOR ANY POTENTIAL
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO. GO TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ON ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IF ANY WAS IN
SUPPORT OF YOU COULD PLEASE
STAND AT THIS TIME AND HEAD OVER
TO THE MICROPHONE TO MY LEFT.
SEEN KNOWING STAND OUT WE ARE
GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GONNA
ASK OUR MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINE TO ANYONE WHO IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL SENATE BILL
FOR EIGHTEEN MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP ALL LINES FOR
THOSE. IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU HAVE
ABOUT SIX THANK YOU AT THE
MOMENT. START WITH LINE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
RYAN SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
SPENCER APPRECIATE THAT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CARE MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
OKAY THAT WE GOT BROWN CALLING
IN THANK YOU SO MUCH DISCOVER
NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MALAZAN BAFF AS JAY YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANKS SO
MUCH MAN LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU IN
BREAKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ALL RIGHT YOUR MONIQUE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT SB FOUR ONE EIGHT THANK
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY THIS CURRENT ACCESS LINE
PLEASE. ONE SIXTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CRUZ AND THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. OF YOUR PHONE CALL
THANK YOU DISCOVER NEXT CALLER.
NEXT LEVEL LINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAVE A GARDEN
SALAS WITH KAISER PERMANENTE A
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
HELP APPRECIATED THIS GOVERNING
CALLER PLEASE. LINE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
SHERRIN MEMBERS ASHLEY WALKER
WITH NOT THE MEN ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF MONTEREY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASHLEY THAT'S CORRECT NINE
PLEASE. LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MARKET
THAT WHILE WITHTHE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH MARKETS THAT'S OUR NEXT
LINE MODERATE. LINE SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. STORY GROWTH IN DON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HIS DATE
THAT THAT ONLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTER IN THE REGION SERVED BY
THE HOSPITAL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
<c.cyan>OR THROWS FOR COLIN THAT'S</c>
CORRECT CALLER. IN THIS YEAR
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MODERATOR WILL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU. THANK YOU JOHN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE BRINGING IT BACK
HERE TO ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THOSE WHO YOU WE JUST HEARD FROM
FOLKS WHO WERE SUPPORTIVE WHEN
OUR TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
POTENTIAL OPPOSITION. WE'RE
GONNA ASK ANYONE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL TO
PLEASE STAND HEAD OVER THE
MICROPHONE TO MY LEFT. SEEN
KNOWING STAND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO BACK TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LIFELINE. MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE OPPOSED
TO SENATE BILL. FOR EIGHTEEN NOW
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND IF
EUROPE. WHICH TO OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE THAT LAYS IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY. SENATOR
DORADO I DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME MISTER I SURE DID YOU WANT
TO SPEAK. ARE THANK YOU SO MUCH
INTEREST YOUR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YES
PLEASE- MR CENTER. WHAT TO.
MILLION MISSUS IN TERMS QUICKLY
SCANNING IT BUT WANTED TO SEE
THEIR RELATIONSHIP ALIVE CALL
PROCESS ANOTHER SOME REFERENCES
TO A BUT IF YOU COULD JUST GIVE
US SOME. LUMINATE THAT'D
APPRECIATE YES- ARE NORMALLY A
DISTRICT WOULD GO THROUGH THE
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION.
FORMATION COMMISSION LASKO
PROCESS WHAT HAPPENED BECAUSE OF
THE SPEED OF THIS IS THAT WE MAP
THE GROUP MAP WITH LIFE GOES ON
BOTH SIDES THEY SAID GO AHEAD
WITH THE BILL IT WAS A
COMMITMENT TO WORK IF THEY HAD
ANY RESIDUAL ISSUES WITH THEM
AFTERWARDS AND I COMMITTED IF
THERE WAS ANY NEED FOR CLEAN UP.
TO DO IT SO THEY HAVE BASICALLY-
HAVE THE BASE TOUCH. AND IF THEY
HAVE ANY REMAINING CONCERNS WE
WILL ADDRESS THEM BUT WE HAVE TO
MOVE THIS BILL IN EIGHTEEN DAYS
AND THAT'S WHY WE DIDN'T GO TO
EITHER OF THEIR PROCESS
NATIONALLY CERTIFIED OKAY THANK. YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
. SEARCH FOR NEEDED QUESTIONS OR
- CURRENCY NINE UNTIL LATER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO I'M FOR EVERY
BY THE TEST. ONCE A FOR ALL THE
ASSISTANCE THE COMMITTEE AND I.
ASK A LOAN FROM THE WORKING WITH
YOU SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH I AM
WE ALSO TO SAY THANK TO JONATHAN
PETERSON FROM THE GOVERNMENT AND
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE BEEN AT
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE. WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
DRAWS A WHICH IS RETURNED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE MOTION ONCE AGAIN. AND
ABOUT. MOTION IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN SENATOR MCGUIRE HI. WHERE ARE
YOU SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN ON
A SENATOR DORADO. DORADO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
ARGUED SENATOR WIENER. WIENER HI
THAT IS A FIVE ZERO VOTER I
CENTER WIENER AYE DO YOU HAVE A
VERY BRIEF TEN SECOND
PRESENTATION PLEASE- YEAH THE
NEW OR. OUR YOU WITH THE LARA
THE MEETINGS ARE. IMPACTS. THANK
WE DESERVE A ALL LIFETIME AWARD
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY IN AMERICA
IS ONE OF AWARD MANY TIMES AND I
REALLY. AS THE TRASH AND I'M
VERY PROUD OF HIM. GRAYSON JONES
WHO IS PLEASE PLEASE RECEIVE I A
PRE VERY MUCH AND- WELL THE HAS
L. TO IT THE ASK OF THE OF THE
MOST. IS THAT IT IS NAMED THE-
AND WE- INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
CAL. WHO IS A JUST AN
EXTRAORDINARY PUBLIC SERVANTS
AND FOR THAT I AM DEEPLY HONORED
I THANK YOU SIR HI DM. THANK
MISTER CHAIR LET ME THANK THE CA
FOR THE VOTE IN A PA. FOR
CREATING THE NEED FOR THE AWARD
. THERE YOU GO EXACTLY THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU SO WHEN YOU'RE IN
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S HERTZBERG
WE ARE NOW AT YOUR.